donc je vais parler de Grave
Encounters of Grave Encounters dans
le comté de Garrard,
une ferme récente s'épanouit, j'espère que
tout le monde en parlait et
vous louait, pensez que c'est ça, allons vérifier
ouais, sécurisez suffisamment de boules de sécurité,
éteignez la caméra nous '  Je partirai, il n'est pas
nécessaire de me donner la cassette, de me donner la cassette en
essayant de cacher quelque chose dont ils ne veulent pas que les
gens ce soir, tu vas
découvrir ce que c'est,
c'est comme dans le film, cet endroit est
effrayant, il y a des esprits avec  nous en
ce moment parlons librement est-ce que vous les gars d'accord
nous sommes venus ici à la recherche de preuves que Grave
Encounters était réel
que faites-vous ici nous sommes de retour d'
une pause publicitaire prolongée le reste de
la distribution n'est plus avec nous